[Music]
rick is with us rick's in las vegas hi
rick what's up man
hey good good afternoon can you guys
hear me okay absolutely how are you
hey good hey uh it's an honor to talk to
you guys today and
i've been listening to your show for a
long time and just really enjoyed
gleaning the wisdom you had to share
with the world
and thank you for that thank you and uh
just have to say that
i love your multiple personalities all
your uh
your dave ramsey personalities they're
just all superstars and i love it so
thank you yeah very kind but i i just
wanted to ask real quick my wife and i
are working on baby sets four
five and six and in looking at our
monthly budget
we're curious about ratios for personal
spending
over the last four or five years our
income has doubled
and but our monthly our blow money has
just kind of stayed constant
i'm curious do you have any kind of
rules or rule of thumb i guess or ratios
for that
uh no there's some principles to put
around it uh number one when you're in
four five and six you're no longer
in gazelle intensity you you are in
inten you move from intensity to
intentionality
and so all i want you to be doing now is
doing stuff on purpose which is what
you're doing by asking this question
so that's excellent uh number two
principle is if your blow category
really should have it's so
big that it really you know i've seen
i've met people that half of their
budget was blow category because they
wouldn't categorize it
and so they just throw it all in the
miscellaneous category because it's lazy
it's intellectual laziness then
um and so if the print you know and so
if
you're if 50 of your budget is your blow
category that means you should have put
categories to some of it you know what
i'm saying like food is not blow money
that kind of thing
or eating out or his eating out his
lunches
while he's at work that might be at a
category rather than
a blow category if your blow category is
getting too large your fun category is
getting too large
the other extreme is when people get it
down to the infinitesimal and they've
got like six dollars
in there and they make 300 000 a year
you know and that's just
it starts to be that's that's when
you've gotten legalistic and you need to
relax and let up so those are kind of
the three things that are going on
so what's your household income
so we're about 160 right now okay and so
how much is is allocated for
your fund money how much is occasion for
hers
uh we each get 150 a month not enough so
it's about two percent yeah not enough
for i mean two percent of our income i
guess you know
i mean when you make that kind of money
that's not enough
yeah okay you need you probably need
double that
okay yeah that's kind of what i was
thinking 300 a month when you make 160
000 a year is not going to mess up your
get wealthy plan
i have a question for both dave and rick
all right so dave here's my question
rick you put some details to it is a
good exercise day for both of them to
kind of go
what do i want to do we've worked hard
we've sacrificed as you said they're no
longer in that gazelle intensity they're
in four five and six
still discipline still focused but is
there an activity that is good for
either them
as a couple or individuals so you know
dave and i love the game of golf you
know rick i don't know what your hobby
would be
but is that a good exercise to start and
go if i did that some within reason
to kind of come to that number or is it
good to just kind of go well let's
double it or let's triple it
feels like to me it should be on purpose
for that for that account
there's not that much money no it's not
as a percentage
so pocket money so rick what would you
like to do more of i guess is my
question
um i've kind of uh you know one of those
utah gun nuts i like to save up and
buy you know guns and ammo and
it's great not like a scary kind of gun
not but just kind of a hobbyist kind of
a deal you know
and uh i like to go out to lunch
sometimes with the guys at work and
and things like that so yeah so there we
go we have two activities
i would separate the guns out of this
and i would say i have a gun category
right i'm saving up for that and if she
wants a purse category i don't care
uh because every time i buy another gun
it costs me another purse it's just it's
a swap out but the uh
uh that's good though but the you know
the the the uh
the lunch with the buddies is one camera
lunch with the buddies is miscellaneous
that's a that's an occasional thing
this is more impulse things little
things nickel dime things
pocket money i use mine uh for tips
like you know you know where my car is
parked with the valet
in front and it stays there
you know why because how much freaking
money i gave him yes
because he's out there in the cold and
he's parking an expensive car or in the
rain or the heat and he's parking
expensive cars probably working my get
out of debt plan
and so that's what a lot of my pocket
money goes for but i you know you just
decide what you want
it's like pocket money that's what it's
for but if you've got a category gun is
a category
i could say tipping is a category and i
could just have a tip
thing if i wanted to walk around the tip
jar in my pocket i guess but
uh but that's you know where does your
cash
go that's just walking you know front
front pocket of your pants where's that
cash going to go
and it ought to be fairly simple
normally fairly inexpensive things
normally and that that's what we get to
so it's a good question it's a good
exercise here's the good news about the
whole discussion with you rick
you guys are doing it on purpose you
move from intensity to intentional
yeah and as long as you're being
intentional and you're being thoughtful
now you're telling your money what to do
you're not going to be wondering where
it went you're not going to fall back
into stupid
all of that's there although that's part
of the category